this true story
Patricia Ann takin's boy brain Senegal
drop it I was in the school but when I
was in school I was getting raped
molested by my dad's a hug right here
it's awesome the group like Google
we-well Groupon Groupon yeah yeah they
dug me out as my mom died age I was
before I was six years old six years old
where did she go she died in an accident
using drugs and [ __ ] my daddy was
beating her my stepdad he was be there
and he caused a lot of pain here so he
died is the he died our out come after
her cuz he you know drove the [ __ ] I'm
only child
oh my mama she tried real hard come see
me went before she died
and my brother uncle he's raping me
after you died he took revenge I mean
it's my it's my duty so I turned the
drills its final six
Oh seventeen and with the prison behind
him go to prison be I want to tear him
down to prison trying to do I was trying
to do I try to zoo try it because case I
I don't stretch ever I didn't with Sam
because it's made me if I knew what new
now our Dino time cuz rape is rape
incest is this and nightmares still
Thursday I'm talking to reading up and I
got myself run around Shutterfly myself
started I gotta I lose a lot of people
in the process that I'm doing about this
but still if gas is different I won't
I gotta reach the abuses if this doesn't
touch the region I got ratio a
relationship I'm in rigid with this
would you yeah with his girl okay
she still drives of [ __ ] she talked down
to me she talk down on me he gives up
off dress yeah so I got stress because I
thought in gear better but she talked
down to tea she got means right [ __ ]
that's why I'm tired now
I'm a shut up you
I'm sorry and I live old town street
military people see much [ __ ]
come here tighter granny thank God again
they can't do it so processes I'm silly
give my dog it's fights with my dogs
calm down
sliced oh my god dollar-a-year it's our
over to blows air they sold him to two
blues era it's someone after over there
he worth more than I raised him that's
why I think that's why they kept me
alive and dog my sir my dog God never
get enriched it
she tried this she better hurry I'm
stealing from a dog gasps it's a
gramophone no my dog my keeper I'm a
zebra I love God very very much God
knows who I am even though I don't know
who I am she did she better mean we got
so different
we're not perfect we got I believe in
you God makes mistakes
so I'm God God he's human Qi are you
going to change it's a shame you did
you've a lot of different things
I don't like them Dean I'm strong
mine are a big fizzy you mostly it's
pure joy if I leave here hopefully I'll
start soon get better I pray every night
four times three times day I know you
can't understand me Emma's it's very
very touching because I who I am
because the things I go do but my
perfect you guys are perfect so no I do
I do I do I do to keep me from doing die
the every male's do send himself drugs
and [ __ ] I'm not gonna do that
god I got that for you I was a prison
and I present in my time
I would change the for attempted murder
yeah because you read me
yeah I did six years eight months at the
time since it's ten years if I said I
did six years
imma hit all three prisons one time they
were friends before neighborhood I have
not been met to really sits there J
Lynette I remember please got probation
I'm on the bill pay worth I'm not gonna
dress up my perfect I just got better
so yeah better than I was before
thank God help a program and people that
can take that my friends and people are
you so I'm just me just me right here
you said me just so I am inside out I'm
sorry
nobody could have sent me they don't
love me good luck so I'll be around
don't worry I'm got got me yeah I was
clean no I was doing mess a little bit
but I I stopped doing it because I lost
a close friend just recently her her
husband he left her right there dead he
took the money and oh and ran
he's here there and ran at it as
assuming that's not telling us man
he's shooting in here she's a christen
this Who I am and God it's gonna be
better I believe in God just like you do
you're strong man you take on lot of
stories where they figured out that
sting got it in but you are as men
you're not perfect you but you've got a
lot of heart more needs man I hear you
are man
he's made a serum and a now they just
have finally so but you are man
and God loves you I love you images are
you like me
we're imperfect where it normally when I
have them on we you me and you got it
got it uh got its little inclusion and
that's what it is yep
now I'm going day whatever you guys
believe me on days
thank you thank you telling about your
energies so beautiful nobody tells you
yeah